hi i'm john cho i am daniela pineda and
this is the wired auto complete
interview
[Music]
i feel like at some point you need to do
the hard kung fu zoom in to john's face
and he says junkundo
yes
[Music]
oh yes
who is john cho yeah yeah man
next i don't know i'm i'm
i'm working on it it's in progress who
is john cho's best friend that's a weird
one because i'm so
i'm a grown man
okay
who does john chow
relate to who do you relate to john
what does that mean
i don't know
you know who uh this is a serious answer
i always say with cal pen
we really have a bond a professional
bond in the sense that like we're in a
very specific space harold and kumar go
to white castle i know what it's like to
be him and he knows what it's like to be
me yeah that's a great answer what is
john cho
in how i met your mother oh god i'm
trying to remember because i've been in
over a hundred film and television
projects i remember i fed
kobe lobster to
there's some lobster joke there i'm
sorry i don't remember you've been in so
many how do you remember is daniela
pineda
in jurassic park i am in jurassic world
i would love to be in jurassic park the
original but i was like very young i am
in the second and third installment of
the new jurassic world series is daniela
pineda
on social media yes i am on instagram at
not daniella pineda
i mean we all have burner accounts where
we spy on people um is daniela pineda
does daniella donate a do comedy i
haven't done stand-up but i was this
close when i was first starting out and
i thought that that was something that
was gonna happen and now it's sort of a
lightweight regret that i have but who
knows you never know
we should do a comedy together we should
does daniela pineda
have tattoos i do i have one large
tattoo that i got in college before i
thought about the rest of my life and
it's huge and it's on this arm and i'm
gonna live with it forever
it's a it's a phoenix
would be so funny that just hit the
light
wait more ah
but this is unfair
what
what was joncho i mean what was that
that john cho what was john cho first
movie
yellow nice what was that coming of age
movie uh
about a bunch of kids who uh
oh man i'm struggling to remember the
plot um are you mixing up with american
pie which joncho was also in yeah and
then there was a mom that i wanted it
was a hot mom oh yeah and um we went on
a spaceship
are you serious
no
i was like really that's crazy what
what happened to james
what the happened to john joe
um john cho is killing it on a
sick hit netflix show that's what
happened to john cho boom what kind of
question is that
hey internet yeah off what's up
what has step off
okay they're still coming for you john
cause look what has john cho been in
what hasn't he been in internet
know your place
what has jon cho's been in okay yeah
john cho's been
in
the next one's just gonna be what cho
what
is john cho
and cowboy bebop joncho
is uh spike spiegel in cowboy bebop okay
okay
here we go
this is so much easier when it's you not
me
who
who is daniela pineda i don't know she's
some chick she's on that thing um the
yeah
all right who was
daniela pineda
in the originals ah i was uh sophie
devereaux in the originals a witch who
they killed off mid-season season one
and they decided to give me a death
where i bled out of all of my orifices
that is
an all-time great character name so
sophie deveraux that's a good name
that's an all time
who does daniella pineda remind me of
julia roberts sandra bullock
nicole kidman there could be a lot of
greats from the 90s who
is daniela pineda
in cowboy bebop daniella pineda is faye
valentine in the new cowboy bebop amen
all right oh i love it when it's not me
and when it's you oh my god oh wait this
is both of us both of us cowboy bebop
one year
i know this one
2071. that's my answer is are we correct
okay the day timothy chalamet gets his
19th oscar
that's so true though if you want to be
on our show you can i'm just kidding
34th does cowboy bebop have gore yeah
cowboy bebop do have gore yeah do have
gore much gore but not al gore when we
needed him does canneries like cowboy
bebop i don't know what keanu reeves i
actually do know this because i met him
and i talked to him about it and he had
a lot of burning questions and yes keanu
reeves loves our show really that's
confirmed yeah i talked to him like we
we had a moment
where was this this was an 87-11 his
stunt gym where we trained all right is
ed in cowboy bebop
live action are we yes
live are we allowed to no no
where's egg i don't know where's ed
why is it called cowboy bebop that's a
deep question it's a layered layered
laser bebop is jet black's ship but it's
also derived from the jazz form
bebop which is quintessential to the
essence of the show and cowboys are what
the bounty hunters are called in that
world but it also does spaghetti the
spaghetti western
genre it's a really it's almost like how
much time do you have because that's a
very layered question for our show i
think we've done it though yeah
i thought after the first one we were
done no they keep but i was incorrect do
you see that stack
oh this is good are you ready for this
is spike spagel
a cowboy yes a cowboy is a slang term
for a bounty hunter in the world of
cowboy bebop so yes he is 100
is spike spiegel in cowboy bebop said
oh
yeah
what is spike spiegel's
ship name i guess possessives aren't
popular on the
internet
the bebop
or
that's jets
ship the swordfish the yeah swordfish
the swordfish the swordfish
does spike spiegel have a fake eye
i don't think he has a fake eye
hang on a second before we get into hot
water is there some reference we don't
know about this is a common
misconception because people mistake
sammy davis jr and
spike spiegel a lot i'm just trying to
touch on references that the kids yeah
sammy davis will resonate with the kids
who the is that what is
spike cowboy bebop fighting style do you
think that we will adopt internet search
language people will just be like nice
meet you seems like from an evolutionary
standpoint that's where we're headed
yeah um jeet kune do is his fighting
style um although he borrows he seems
like he does whatever he needs in in
whatever situation but ji kundo
oh boy
is faye valentine
immortal what
she was frozen but that's because of the
help of of modern technology but she is
by no means immortal that would make her
like a god and she's definitely just a
regular lady
what is faye valentine
personality fun scrappy brassy
marshmallowy on the inside wow
that was concise yeah and and vivid i've
been with her for quite some time now
dufay dufay answer the question dufay
doofy
and spike get together no no no were you
sad
you know i was like could it go there
but honestly i feel like if you did that
fans would be like burning down sets and
stuff yeah because that's so like a hard
no it does fake
in cowboy bebop use knife yes yes i do
small little sharp one that fits
right in between here the internet
search language does
sound like a sushi chef
[Music]
i will say though if you don't speak
english
and then this is what you're putting in
this is actually really impressive if
you were a non-english speaker so shout
out to all my non-english speakers
okay is joncho
apologies but yes
is john cho
a gemini from what people tell me are
gemini traits uh they're all horrible
things uh two-faced
liars uh all of that
yes it's accurate is john cho
in cobra kai that's what you call soft
racism
um
no yeah no i do happen to know the
creators of cobra two of them uh
created harold and kumar go to white
castle which i don't want to brag
i was herald uh but
it's kind of a big deal so we're joking
around here it could happen yeah and if
they have like the hot teacher that like
hooks up with the students and the
season five
let me know is john cho in new zealand
i'm not in new zealand correct are we in
new zealand no
i am no longer in new zealand but uh i
had a good time thank you our john chow
are there multiples of you
are john cho and cow pen friends we are
i love that guy it's legal in california
so i can say this but as a uh forever
slight pothead
your movie was very inspirational to me
thank you thank you for making that
movie
it means a lot to me i appreciate it
give us a moment
i'm like not kidding that was like very
a very affirming movie i think for a lot
of people okay
how daniella panetta oh no i don't i
already know where this is going how old
is daniela pineda next question how did
daniela pineda
get into acting it was on accident i was
trying to be
a writer director acting was never on
the table and then acting as something
that chased me down and found me and
here i am but that was never the
intention
i was not trying to act
i just
kind of finds me how how to be danielle
pineda i mean
care about your education care about
succeeding and then couple that with a
five milligram sativa you'll be good
how
how to cosplay danielle pineda i don't
know if you can cosplay me as a person
just copy this
how to get what daniela what's this
faye haircut oh
it's a bob it's a bob and then diet
purple
all right oh these are house how
old is john cho i'm 49
you're 30
how tall is john cho 510 there you go
i'm so into this next question how was
john cho's show it's good
it's good i mean we had our ups and
downs but we're here and it was good
yeah
how many movies has john cho
been in care to name your entire imdb
list
i'm going to say 25. how many imdb
credits credits do you have i mean i
check every tuesday i like c so i check
my star meter i checked i'm assuming you
do the same i'm gonna
i'm gonna guess 75. it's 114. it's
pretty good pretty good bragging right
you know you don't get to
own a condo in bakersfield
without putting in the work hey shout
out to bakersfield yay
we did it
[Music]